AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME,
BUZZSPEED.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
BUZZFEED IS FULL OF RIDICULOUS
LISTS LIKE 22 CARTOON DADS WHO
ARE MOST DEFINITELY DILFS.
OR 11 CATS WHO DON'T GIVE A
[BLEEP] YOU'RE HUNG OVER.
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO COME UP
WITH BUZZFEED LISTS THAT ARE
SOMEHOW MORE RIDICULOUS THAN THE
ONES THAT ARE ACTUALLY ON
BUZZFEED.
I WILL GIVE YOU 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
STEVE AGEE.
>> 87 BARS THAT ALLOW YOU TO
BREASTFEED YOUR DOG.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
SCOTT.
>> 26 LETTERS YOU SIMPLY MUST
ARRANGE INTO WORDS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
SARAH.
>> 12 OBSCURE STAR WARS
CHARACTERS THAT ARE MAYBE PAUL
GIAMATTI.
>> HUTTON: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> FIVE QUOTES FROM SHREK YOU
CAN USE AT YOUR NEXT PAROLE
HEARING.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
STEVE AGEE.
>> 20 TITS THAT DON'T MATCH.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
SCOTT.
>> TWO PEOPLE THAT GOT DIVORCED
BECAUSE YOU WERE BORN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, SARAH.
>> TWO... KOREAS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> 250 REASONS WHY KIRSTIE ALLEY
SHOULD HAVE A SALAD.
(GROANING)
OOH. OOH.
>> HARDWICK: HEY. YOU KNOW WHO
THAT SOUNDS LIKE, SARAH.
>> SOUNDS LIKE MY EX-WIFE.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
>> YEAH!
>> OH!
(BELL DINGS)
>> HARDWICK: SARAH.
>> EIGHT LINDSAYS THAT WERE A
REAL BITCH AT DINNER LAST NIGHT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.